hallo leute und willkommen wenn zu einem
neuen video und heute retten wir
packen's kriselt dadurch die letzte
rettung von captain cook so gefallen hat
dachte ich machen wir heute mal gleich
weiter und retten paar noten käsekuchen
vor ungefähr an die hand zu backen sich
noch nicht sagen wie er ist absolut
furchtbar herausgekommen wie ich vor 25
jahren witze auf eigene kosten im westen
wird der welt hey palm dessen locke war
gut das wissen wir alle und deshalb
stellt er nicht mal die zutaten vor aber
laufen des videos findet man ungefähr
heraus was in diesen kunden sollen
programmspeicher 250 gramm butter 250
gramm zucker und mehl und weibern ist ja
nur feinste cuisine gibt machen wir noch
die traumzahlen rhein wo das zucker und
noch mehr butter und kekse nur echt mit
215 und nach das mittel aus nein
natürlich nicht man das war an der
vorstellung war es uncool
also lasse ich die kugel spiegel
beginnen
auf die melodie von katniss gas ist
ketten des picanto schicken jetzt fragen
wir so erstmals möglich immer unsere
kräfte mit einer hand nachdem der letzte
punkt auch so anstrengend ich ob ich
jetzt wirklich noch mal einen kuchen
machen möchte
aber dann hat es jemand in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich mal von
piloten das rennen war dann nach new
york wisst ihr was macht das schon
ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie
jemanden gesehen der mika newton so
chaotisch kocht also einfach alles in
eine schlüssel gibt und dann mixed und
damit eine andere schüssel backt und
dann mixa in mixa rein und sauerei
veranstaltet also jedem hobby bäcker
blutet da ist das herz händewaschen ich
auch irgendwann habe ich mit lama fahren
natürlich kommt zum einen noch ein
bisschen so und jetzt während es rührt
geben wir 250 gramm zucker rein ist ich
habe mir eine andere schüsse und jetzt
kommen wir zum stars haben vielleicht
war es einfach ein kino in die schüssel
rhein zum magerquark kommen jetzt die
eigelbe
[Musik]
die payom jetzt sagen würde die bruder
folgt jetzt erst mal das schöne reihe
neuer das sieht gut aus aber das sieht
länger audio ich bin hin und nach video
ja ich würde mal sagen das sind jetzt
fantastisch aus da kommt jetzt noch ein
bisschen zitronenschale waren aber leute
ganz wichtig das muss eine bio zitrone
sein sonst besteht jetzt brauchen wir so
eine reihe ebene sowas zu rasten oder
hobby opfers gefunden hier eine so eine
schöne raspel wir machen jetzt einfach
so ein bisschen die schau ab und du
sagst wenn sie da so rein nicht das
weiße das ist weder ein klopfen
ich sag mal so bei einem kilo magerquark
hat auch ein bisschen mehr warten 100
gramm dürfen auf keinen fall fehlen
wenn jemand abteilungen fleurs du mal
möchten
das ist der beste moment warum stehen
alle auf personen also ich find ihn auch
sehr süßer ist also in dem video seien
was für movistar glaube aber auch alle
mein fasten müssen einfach süß und zum
verlieben aussehen
sie halten jetzt schon mal die großen
auf 200 grad ober und unterhitze oder
weniger oder mehr je nach dieser ofen
hört auf euren ofen ja hallo martin
gucken direkt in die form gegeben ich
werde noch eine knusprigen kriegszeit
wohnen machen da wird es jetzt erstmal
so gut aus
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt etwas extrem dumm ist
und zwar willig die krümel in die
schüssel geben und ich habe keine ahnung
ob das war gerade einen tag alt und da
haben die wehrleute der weg ist nicht
das ziel des zieles ziel sei jetzt haben
wir so kriegst grüne passagierzahl boden
zu mir
also ganz ehrlich das sieht doch nicht
mal so schlecht aus
jetzt kommt unsere extrem flachen papi
marquardt mischung dar ein
[Musik]
ich weiß ja auch nicht ob es so schlau
was ich an einem rezept von vermuten zu
halten aber jetzt gibt es kein zurück
mehr
das ist amerika wo also und das muss
jetzt in den ofen bis braun ist ich
denke mal so eine stunde aber nicht
weniger
[Musik]
platz und dann versuchen wir drehen
jetzt schön er wird bestimmt rein sinken
ich habe immer noch nicht gecheckt die
mannschaft das jungtier so perfekt
gerade ist und nicht so ein punkt drin
hat und jetzt kommen wir zur schrift
versuchen schreibt das einbuchen
minecraft free dem käse konnte
ich muss jetzt leider gestehen dass ich
nicht weiß was minecraft freedom heißt
er hat dort verloren und alle leute die
jetzt minecraft spielen
doch die will ich weiß es war ogi bbt
und frieden und das ist wahrscheinlich
überhaupt nicht miteinander zu
vergleichen mannschaft ist auch nie bei
mir angekommen ich habe hagedorn
gespielt ich habe hier muss auf system
gespielt ich habe
golf war gerade gezockt noch andere
spiele habe es nun welche dame hat nun
diese das video hat 700.000 auf und da
merkt ihr dass es auf youtube nicht
darauf ankommt dass man alles perfekt
und supermacht sondern einfach dass man
den leuten eine gute zeit gibt und ein
lustiges video raushaut also wenn das
700.000 aufrufe hat und 50.000 likes
dann bekommen wir doch bestimmt
mindestens 25.000 seit leute so like
button und aktiviert die glocke an
dieser stelle tun es einfach mal
probiert es ausschaut machen wie ihr
euch fühlt wenn sie mitten am tag ihr
handy sagte wenn es ein neues video
hochgeladen es ist wie ein gruß von
einem guten freund der euch gerne hat
wir machen unsere eigene zucker schritt
dafür brauchen wir auf jeden fall sehr
viel puderzucker
das war dieses schöne sie traum hier
haben kann wieder ein bisschen sagt auch
gleich dreimal ohne internen verpacken
mal 200 gramm butter dazu in seiner
butter zucker schmeckt super
[Musik]
hier haben wir jetzt unseren käsekuchen
und ich habe ihn wirklich selber aus dem
ofen rausgeholt liegt gar nicht mal so
schairer aus ich muss euch dazu sagen
das ist mein erster käse gucken wen ich
in meinem leben gemacht habe wir lassen
den gucken jetzt abkühlen und gleich
machen wir mit der schrift weiter wenn
ihr sherlock denke dann auch mal bei
seinem bruder minecraft in minecraft der
name war wird nicht sehr rosig aus ich
schaue jetzt nicht nach wie man
minecraft schreibkraft wie verbandes mit
gross bestand natürlich
[Musik]
ok das ergebnis lässt sich sehen ich
zeige ich euch jetzt insgesamt und
absolut erfolgt
[Musik]
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich hätte nicht
erwartet dass sie so gucken dann doch so
cool rauskommt und so also ganz ehrlich
wenn ich ein kind was minecraft spielt
macht ein käsekuchen und schreibt
minecraft drauf ist er nicht berufen ist
absolut fantastisch
und nun stehen wir natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt paar
lutens meint freedom käsekuchen gerettet
vom captain kuchen ok bruder boden
boden ist super geworden die zitrone
schmeckt man feuer aus und damit würde
ich sagen gerettet gibt es irgendwo mal
gesehen dass man klickt zugleich machten
sie dann als figuren boden benutzt und
das wirklich super tipp
ich habe euch die folge gefallen und
wenn wir auf panzern nach macht dann
schickt mir auf jeden fall ein bild das
man auf instagram oder mit einer
brieftaube und wenn euch die folgenden
hat da nicht vergessen daumen nach oben
und die dort aktivieren das bild sehr
gut weiter und wenn noch kein abonnent
bis abonniere diesen kanal komm schon
hier gibt absolut premium videos früher
haben die leute immer gesagt aber es
umsonst
das alles umsonst ist kostet dich nicht
mehr was für alle anderen sachen musste
bezahlen
parallel gibt es gratis ich auch zu
labern und liebe grüße schießt ich finde
ich richtig süß danke tschüss